Well, he'll be speaking on the subject of
reproducibility.
Next slide, please.
I want to tell you all about John, but I need
the next slide to do that.
There we go.
John is a professor of medicine, health research
and policy, and biomedical data science at
Stanford.
He came to international fame, I would say,
many years ago, when he published his provocative
paper on why the results of most biomedical
studies are false.
And has continued to spend the rest of his
career helping people understand why science
is not always as reproducible as we might
think.
He also, at Stanford, directs the PhD program
in epidemiology and clinical research.
He Is co-director of a major new initiative
at Stanford called the Meta-Research Innovation
Center, which is looking precisely at areas
of scientific reproducibility, has an endowed
chair in the Center for Disease Prevention
at Stanford University, and is someone who
at Stanford is ubiquitous and someone whom
everyone respects.
And I'm really looking forward to hearing
what he has to say this morning.
John, it's up to you
Thank you, Mark, It's a great pleasure to
participate in this series and to try to discuss
a pretty convoluted topic of reproducibility.
There's a lot of confusing terminology to
start with.
People are talking about reproducibility,
but they're also talking about replication.
And then, you can hear exact replication,
and conceptual replication, reanalysis, repeatability,
corroboration, triangulation.
All these terms have been out there for a
long time, but they're currently being revisited
as we are facing new challenges and new dilemmas
with new types of studies, new types of data,
and new challenges on what reproducibility
means.
This is showing how often the term reproducibility
is used across all domains of science.
There's an exponential growth over time in
the popularity of this terminology.
Basically, we can think of three types of
reproducibility-- reproducibility of methods,
reproducibility of results, and reproducibility
of inferences.
Reproducibility of methods is the ability
to understand or repeat as exactly as possible
the experimental and computational procedures.
So if you have some software and some script,
if you use the same software and the same
script, you should be able to get the same
conclusion if you also have the same data.
So it's an issue of performing a reanalysis
or kind of repeating and getting the same
result out of the same package.
Sometimes it may not be exactly the same result.
So for example, if you have a permutation
procedure and you run it two different times,
you may not get exactly the same result; but
if the result is substantially different,
then you should start to worry about something
not being exactly what you thought it should
be.
Reproducibility of results is something that
usually we use the term "replication," which
means that we're performing a new study.
We are collecting new data, new observations,
new participants, new whatever.
And we
want to produce corroborating results in that
new experiment having followed the same observational
or experimental method as we did in the original
study.
So people will talk about exact replication
when they try to do exactly the same thing.
Obviously, it's never possible to do exactly
the same thing.
There will always be some deviation from what
was done in the first study-- minor or major
sometimes.
And therefore, this leads to potential for
debate, and this leads to reproducibility
of inferences, which is the making of knowledge
claims of similar strengths from a study replication,
or from multiple studies, or from a body of
evidence.
Different people see the same results, and
they reach different conclusions on what these
mean because of different backgrounds, different
conflicts of interest, different beliefs,
different priors, or different understanding
on what the results mean.
There's differences across scientific fields
that effect also what we mean by reproducible
research.
It's not the same in sociology, in physics,
in medicine, in bioinformatics.
There's a great variance in the degree of
determinism that these fields have.
The signal to measurement error ratio and
can be substantially different.
The complexity of the designs and the measurement
tools can also vary a lot.
The closeness of fit that we are seeking between
the hypothesis and the experimental design
and data may also be different.
The statistical and analytical methods that
are used to test hypotheses-- some of them
get entrenched within statistic scientific
heterogeneity of experimental results may
vary-- usually it's higher in social science
disciplines than in biomedical disciplines
and higher in biomedical disciplines compared
to physical sciences.
Well, if there is even a culture of replication
transparency, and cumulating knowledge, some
fields are very open, and they're sharing
software, code, data, protocols, as a [? pinpoint
?] [? on.
?] Others don't share much or anything.
Some fields are willing to perform replications
and they feel that unless they do that, it's
not going to be believable no matter what
they come up with.
In other fields, the replication [? is ?] a
[? me-too ?] waste of time.
The statistical criteria of truth claims can
vary substantially.
Many fields in biomedicine are stuck with
p-values less than 0.05, being enough to claim
a discovery or some sort of finding while
in-- [? omits ?] p-values of 10 to the minus
8 are sought pretty much routinely.
Some fields are completely abandoning p-values.
They're using a false discovery rate or base
factors.
And some fields are in transition using different
modalities that sometimes reach different
conclusions when it comes to reproducibility
of inferences.
Finally, there's differences to the purposes
to which findings will be put in the consequences
of false conclusions.
So some scientific findings may be interested
in some very fancy mechanistic view of life
or some phenomena,
and this may have very little repercussions
for life and death.
But other studies may make inputs into accommodations
that affect the treatment of millions of people
and obviously, their outcomes-- including
life and death.
This is a map of 20 million papers published
in the last 15 years.
It also includes two million [? patterns,
?] and it's an effort to see how many solar
systems exist in this galaxy of science.
There's about 200,000 solar systems of different
scientific disciplines and the different colors
highlight the 13 big clusters.
So life sciences is one such and physics is
another.
But if you look closely, there is 200,000
disciplines, and each one of them may have
its own rules of engagement and its own understanding
about what reproducibility means and how exactly
it should be implemented.
Now when you try to cross the boundaries,
sometimes you see that fields that are seemingly
doing almost the same thing, they have very
different standards about their reproducibility
practices.
The common denominator across almost all fields
is that everybody is trying to come up with
a significant result.
So this is an evaluation of the entire PubMed
worth of 15 million papers since 1990 that
we performed and published last year in JAMA.
And we found that 96% of papers that used
p-values in their abstracts-- they claimed
significant results-- statistically significant
results.
Looking at about a million full-text papers
in PMC, again, 96% of them claimed significant
results and the vast majority of them say
that they're novel.
So if you take that literally, scientific
discovery has become a boring nuisance.
There's just so much of it that we don't really
know what to make of it.
So reproducibility is probably our best chance
at the moment to filter out how many of these
millions of claims are real, true, and potentially
translatable to something that could help
people eventually.
Now in the current environment, this may not
be easy because the typical recipe of research
practices in most biomedical fields is that
you have the prototype of the principal investigator,
who is solo and siloed.
Unavoidably, this means that he or she will
be using mostly studies of small sample sizes
and would be cherry picking one or the best
hypothesis to try to get two significant results.
Because this is the way to then seek funding.
There's a lot of post-hoc analysis being done.
P-value of 0.05 or slightly less is enough
as I said before.
There's no registration of the ideas or the
protocols.
Very little data sharing and no replication,
because replication only has a chance of refuting
or not replicating something that is already
statistically significant.
So people think, why should I waste my time
to kill all the work that I did and then not
be able to publish it in a high-profile journal?
So this is a setting of incentives that don't
really align with reproducible science.
And this is what you get when you have a field
performing in that fashion.
This is looking at about 1800 datasets of
the fMRI studies, and I have plotted for you
the number of foci that have
been discovered as a function of the sample
size.
The only way to discover a lot of foci for
different phenotypes, or features, or tasks
is to perform very small studies.
When we perform larger studies, these foci
go away.
The facts become much smaller.
Most of those disappear, and it's very likely
that most of these claims' discoveries in
very small studies don't really mean much.
This is not just happening in fMRI research.
A couple of years ago, we looked across very
different fields across neuroscience ranging
from early basic research, preclinical research,
clinical research, clinical trials, and the
common denominator was power failure.
We had a paradigm of having a very small sample
size studies that you expect to have major
problems with their reproducibility.
This is another exercise looking at neuroscience,
psychology, medical psychology, and psychiatry
literature-where we did some in-depth text
mining of these studies.
And the common denominator-- even though there
is quite some variability across different
subfields and journals-- is that they have
very small sample sizes, which are likely
to lead to inflated effect sizes and very
often false positive effect sizes, which you
need some replication effort to try to see
whether they stand the test of replication.
This is a completely different field.
This is economics.
Along with Tom Stanley and [? Chris ?] [INAUDIBLE]
we've looked at every single meta-analysis
that we could identify in economics.
This is mostly observational economics as
opposed to experimental economics.
We found 130 topics, more than 10,000 studies,
and more than 70,000 effect estimates.
The common denominator is, again, very small,
very limited power for the majority of [? p
?] studies and these topics.
So you expect to see a similar performance
of observational economics and observational
neuroscience, even though these two disciplines
are so far apart.
There are some fields where we do have the
benefit of having performed replications in
very large scale.
And one such field is genetic epidemiology.
Because in genetic epidemiology, the cost
of performing replications has been very low.
It's very easy and very cheap to genotype
very large sample sizes.
And this is in contrast to what is happening
in many other fields where running the experiments
continues to be very expensive.
So in genetics, we could go back when we moved
into the genome wide association era and test
what we have discovered in the candidate gene
era when we were performing research with
small studies one gene at a time, one hypothesis
at a time, or a few hypotheses at a time.
Their replication rate was 1.2%.
So of all these several tens of thousands
of papers that have been published in the
candidate gene era about associations of single
genes tested against single phenotypes, only
1.2% were validated when they were tested
with very large sample sizes with very accurate
and large-scale genome-wide association studies.
Preclinical research has also seen a flurry
of results that are not looking very nice
in terms of their reproducibility.
Preclinical research has also seen a flurry
of results that are not looking very nice
in terms of their reproducibility.
A series of investigations, mostly run by
the industry, have shown reproducibility rates
ranging from 0% to 25%.
The reason that the industry has led these
efforts is that they do want to use preclinical
research to try to develop new drug targets.
So they use these leads from papers that have
been published by the best investigators in
academia, in the best centers, the best research
institutes, and they want to make sense of
them and translate them into new drugs or
new diagnostics, and it doesn't work.
So when they did that in large-scale research,
25% of these high-profile papers could be
reproduced.
So Glenn Begley wrote in Nature in 2012 that
the failure to win the war on cancer has been
blamed on many factors; but recently, a new
culprit has emerged.
Too many basic scientific discoveries are
wrong.
And that was his conclusion when his team
was able to reproduce only six of 53 landmark
studies for Amgen oncology drug [? target
?] projects.
Now what does it mean to replicate or to reproduce?
This can be contested, obviously, and we don't
really know whether we have the right answer
when we have an original study, or when we
have a replication reproduction effort that
disagrees in one way or another versus the
original study.
It's possible that the original study may
be correct, and the reproducibility effort
may be wrong.
It could be that both are correct, but they
were not really exact replicas of each other.
Or it could be that both of them are actually
wrong and there is some common biases that
they had.
So regardless of whether they agree or they
disagree, they could still be wrong.
But at a minimum, when we have large numbers
of studies, we can start talking about patterns
of reproducibility across different fields,
even though single cases will be heavily debated.
And this is what they call the reproducibility
wars.
So pretty recently, the first results of the
reproducibility project Cancer Biology were
released.
And every single one of these reproducibility
efforts was heavily contested.
So here's one example where the results look
very nice.
You have an effect in the original study that
is significant; you have an effect in the
replication effort.
The meta-analysis also shows an effect.
The effect size is slightly less in the reproducibility,
but that's OK.
But depending on whether you are just, for
example, for multiplicity of analysis, then
the result in the reproducibility may no longer
be statistically significant.
So one might say that we have powered the
reproducibility to be significant, and now
it is not.
But if you don't correct [? for ?] multiplicity
comparison, which is also fair, because if
this is a reproducibility effort, then it
is significant.
This led to a huge debate, even though I don't
really see much debate.
These results seem to be pretty consistent
with each other.
Here's another example where things are clearly
very different.
I mean, you see that if you take panel A,
the effect size, but also the confidence intervals
are very different in the original study.
In the repeatability estimate, you have a
glass delta of 7.41 versus a minus 0.32 and
with pretty tight confidence intervals.
But again, this can lead to a lot of debate,
and there's lots of things at stake here.
It's not just the veracity of the results,
but it's also whatever other investment has
been made into trying to develop the original
study into some translational application.
For example, whether new studies have been
launched, whether clinical trials are being
planned based on these results, whether there
is investment, whether entrepreneurs or venture
capitalists are thinking about giving money
to invest in that original observation that
now seems to be so squarely refuted.
These concerns have been raised increasingly
in a number of fields.
Here's a partial list showing reproducibility
concerns in preclinical studies, on microarray
data, on stroke animal studies [? general
?] biology, oncology, genome sequencing, mouse
in-vivo studies, genealogical studies, mouse
models, genomic [? cell line ?] analysis,
microarray data, commercial antibodies, and
ELISA, and the way that journals handle information
also.
And they pertain to disciplines as different
as science from ecology to genomic bioinformatics,
stem cell biology, oncology, in vitro testing,
chemistry-led discovery, computational biology,
pathology biomarkers, organizational psychology,
and observational research of all sorts.
So my field, if I had to pick one out of many
where I have failed, is probably epidemiology.
And you can see here that zero out of 52 hypotheses
that were claimed in major epidemiological
studies were subsequently confirmed in randomized
trials.
This is a nice paper by Stan Young and Carr
a few years ago.
This is one of the most famous recent reproducibility
attempts.
It's the open science collaboration effort
where 270 investigators and their teams try
to reproduce 100 experiments published in
the top psychology journals.
And the results clearly don't look very nice.
You can see the comparison of p-values and
the effect sizes in the original studies and
their replications.
About a third of the influential papers could
be reproduced.
Depending on how exactly you define reproducibility,
you may have a little bit of a different answer.
But clearly, they seem to be different.
And even when they could be reproduced, the
effect sizes typically were much smaller in
the replications compared to the original
studies.
This has led to a reproducibility war.
So there were technical comments and replies
in science a few months after the publication
of that very influential study.
And some top psychologists felt that there's
nothing wrong.
This is the way that it should be, and actually,
the reproducibility effort is wrong, is not
what it should be.
And there's many reasons.
And there were examples being pursued as really
not being the best efforts to replicate the
original finding.
However, one would wonder if you'd have a
situation where you have [? 217 ?] investigators
and their teams from the best institutions
joining forces performing something with the
best possible methods with perfect transparency,
with everything being reviewed at all stages
by the best peers, if this is found or claimed
to be so wrong and so suboptimal, what would
one think about other studies that really
don't have the benefit of that cumulative
wisdom
and expertise being put in them?
Here's another example.
This is experimental economics.
They have also tried to do their reproducibility
checks, and their reproducibility results
seem a bit better.
About a third of the studies could not be
produced.
It's a small sample.
It's only 18 papers that have been published
in major economics journals, but it seems
a bit better compared to what has been documented
in preclinical research, in biomedicine, and
in psychology.
Now, the difference could be just due to chance,
but it could also be due to the fact that
experimental economics for a number of years
now has followed a number of policies that
we think-- both based on theory and on some
empirical data-- should lead to better reproducibility.
So they do have protocols that are communicated.
They do share all the software and the code,
and all the raw data with other scientists.
And this is also a prerequisite for publication.
So you have a culture where there's openness
and transparency, and a lot of thought goes
into developing protocols.
Plus, you have a culture where you have experimental
results where you expect to see better reproducibility
compared to just observational datasets--
especially observational datasets that sometimes
are not even conceived with a particular purpose
of looking at one specific question that then
gets published.
Here's another side of the reproducibility
debate.
Sometimes effect sizes may not completely
nullifiy upon replication efforts, but they
may become much smaller.
And this is one classic example where we see
this.
In biomarkers studies, if you plot the relative
risk in the highly sited study that typically
has been one of the first ones or the first
one about a biomarker and the relative risk
in the largest study, all the action is below
the diagonal with just a couple of exceptions.
Which means that the largest study finds much
smaller effect sizes.
They're not null, so they're not a relative
risk of one, but they're much smaller compared
to what the original study had found.
So that biomarker still has some ability to
discriminate or predict, but not as much--
far less compared to what the original highly
sited study would have suggested.
Another dimension, as I mentioned before,
is reanalysis or repeatability.
In reanalysis, we're not performing a new
study, we're just going back and re-examining
the data from a study that has been done,
published, and now everybody can scrutinize
because the raw data are available.
So there are some experience of repeatability
checks, and one of them is an effort that
we did jointly with Nature Genetics a number
of years ago.
Nature Genetics was one of the first channels
that made the availability of software protocols
and raw data a prerequisite for publication
for microarray studies.
And when we did that exercise looking at 18
papers that had been published in Nature Genetics,
we could not reproduce more than two of the
18 papers.
Some could be reproduced with discrepancies,
or with discrepancies from process data or
partially, but most could not be reproduced
at all.
And the reason for the nonreproduction was
that the data were not available.
The software was
homemade and had disappeared.
The methods were unclear.
So we had several teams of microarray analysts
around the world who couldn't understand exactly
what was being done in that paper.
Or the result was different even though everything
was available and the methods were very clear,
and the data were there, and the software
could be made to work.
The result was not what had been published
in the original paper.
So this is probably disquieting because we're
talking about the best field in genetics and
one of the best in science at large, and the
most transparent field at that time with avant-garde
ideas about sharing of information, and software,
and methods.
Here's another field where there has been
some expands on reanalysis.
Randomized clinical trial data have mostly
not been available to other investigators,
but this is changing.
In the past, it was very difficult to get
these data, but currently, there's about 20,000
clinical trials worth of data that you can
get hold of one way or another.
Not necessarily completely free access, but
at least you can apply for getting them and
hopefully you can get them.
In the past, there were very, very few such
trials, and we found 37 reanalyses that had
examined the very same question as the original
trial in the very same data.
And we found that 35% of the time, the reanalysis
reached an entirely different conclusion compared
to the original paper.
So the original paper would have claimed that
the patients should be treated, and the reanalysis
would say, no, they should not be treated.
Or the type of patients to be treated would
be different in the original paper, versus
the reanalysis
One might think that this might be some enemies
of the original investigators who are trying
to put them to shame.
But actually, almost always, the original
authors were involved also as co-authors in
the reanalysis, which means that what we have
documented here is likely to be just the tip
of the iceberg.
Probably many, many more reanalyses of randomized
trials were done-- possibly in the hundreds
or even thousands.
But a key attractor for disseminating and
publishing the results of a reanalysis has
been the ability to say that, I found something
new.
So even though these are the same authors,
having found something new and reaching a
different conclusion might have been an incentive
to publish, which makes things very confusing.
But this is the way that the publication system
operates apparently.
There's also an opposite movement moving in
the opposite direction of reproducibility
and transparency that would facilitate reproducibility
checks and reanalysis.
And I call this stealth research, which means
that some organizations and some entities
feel that nothing should be shared, nothing
should be communicated, information should
be kept as trade secret.
There's no need to try to replicate; we will
just do things internally.
We will make sure that they're fine and then
we will [? conquer ?] the world.
And this is pretty much the example upon which
Theranos was built.
So when I wrote that paper in JAMA 2 and
1/2 years, Theranos had published about 100
patents, but practically nothing in the peer-reviewed
literature about its disruptive innovative
method.
So I questioned whether this lack of transparency,
which does not allow anyone to replicate what
they do and reproduce what they do, is the
way to move forward.
And at that time, they were really very powerful,
but within a few months after that investigation
by the Wall Street Journal and scrutiny by
federal regulators and other entities, the
company imploded.
So stealth research didn't seem to be such
a good idea after all.
Some potential solutions to improve reversibility-there's
many such solutions, and I have discussed
some of them already.
As I was going through these examples, some
of them we know that they would work very
well.
Others are very speculated, and we need empirical
evidence as to their efficacy.
There are some solutions that may sound nice,
but they could cost a lot.
They could mean that we need to invest a lot
of effort, and therefore, maybe the trade-offs
are not such that we would recommend them.
For example, one solution might be to replicate
everything-- just to keep on replicating every
single item that you see produced in science
or published in the scientific literature--
probably not a very good investment.
That would mean that we would need to either
double the research budget or somehow cut
our investment in half in terms of what new
ideas we could pursue.
Or another such idea that I think is highly
suspect is, try to audit everything that is
being done.
And this means that I would need to clone
myself, and everybody would need to clone
themselves so that they have the scientists
and the auditor's scientists following as
their shadow wherever they go in the lab or
in their computer to try to reanalyze and
reproduce everything that they do.
Clearly, we cannot do that.
However, there are many things that we could
do, and here's a few examples that belong
to 12 families of reproducibility efforts
that may improve the veracity and the truthfulness
and trustworthiness of the results that we
get.
One option is to promote replication culture
at large.
So embed replication in the discovery phase.
This is what has happened in genetic epidemiology.
People don't really separate that much discovery
from replication because they understand that
replication is part of the discovery.
So this is one out of zillions of Manhattan
plots that you will see in that literature.
In the past, we thought that we had discovered
zillions of genes that could affect smoking
behavior.
And this is what these Manhattan plots are
about.
In the candidate gene era, there were 359
genes that had been discovered as being associated
with smoking behavior.
When we performed large-scale studies where
we had multiple teams replicating each other's
signings and joining all their data instead
of just publishing them one piece at a time,
we could only validate one of these 359.
And we came up with another dozen or so.
It's better to have a dozen that we are very
certain that they're true, rather than have
359 that are completely spurious.
If we do replication, it needs to be inexpensive
and easy to do.
And then, who is going to do it?
Is it going to be the same investigators?
Is it going to be different investigators
of the same school?
of competing theories and hypotheses?
Do we need combinations of the above in some
easy-to-do problems?
Maybe we can open replication to the wide
public.
So lots of mathematics questions can be split
into tens of thousands of computers.
And people could run them in their own desktop
or laptop, and then accumulate that information
at some central facility.
These are questions that cannot be answered
in a generic term.
They need to be seen on a case-by-case basis.
I think that there is some general patterns
that if you have the same investigators trying
to replicate, you unavoidably have some allegiance
bias.
The same applies if you have investigators
of the same school.
So one has to ask, how strong is allegiance
bias likely to be?
Do we have experimental constraints and safeguards
that would alleviate the concern for such
allegiance bias?
And if not, then we probably need to think
of different investigators who try to test
whether the original experiments were correct
and the inferences were valid.
Registration is another possibility.
And this means that if I do have a hypothesis
and a protocol, I would like to register it
upfront so that people would know that this
is what I do.
And there would be full transparency about
all the steps that I have followed so that
people would compare notes with what was the
original intention.
And they could also try to reproduce what
was done at the first place.
This is not always possible.
There's a lot of research I call level-zero
research, blue-sky science.
There can be no registration there because
really, no one has a preconceived deliverable
or hypothesis in mind.
People are just testing like crazy very different
things, and if something pans out, they will
report it.
The only thing that I want in that case is
some transparency.
That this is how this emerged.
That it was completely unrestricted, exploratory
blue-sky science, and there was no plan, this
is what I got.
Now.
We need some replication efforts.
But we can't really claim that there was any
specific hypothesis or protocol that was preset.
Level 1 would be a registration of a dataset,
which means that I can share information on
how many observational datasets I have available.
People would know what the spectrum of multiplicity
is in these datasets.
So when they see a published analysis about
one risk factor with one outcome, they can
immediately tell that that was from a dataset
that includes five million variables, or a
dataset that includes five variables.
That makes a huge difference because if I
have published that analysis with a p-value
of 0.049 from a database that excludes five
million variables, then people might easily
question whether that p-value is really valid
And unless I have preregistered that, it's
very hard to believe that I just closed my
eyes and did not analyze anything else other
than that association.
Level 2 would be registration of the protocol;
and that means that there is a protocol.
Level 3 is registration of the analysis plan;
And that means that there is an analysis plan.
Very often there is a protocol, but there
is no statistical analysis plan.
And this is decided at a late stage after
the data have been collected; and sometimes,
even after some analysis has been done, which
creates some shade of gray into the credibility
of the research.
But sometimes, some of that ambiguity may
be unavoidably true.
Because things don't happen the way that they
were intended during the conduct of the study,
especially in a study with long-term follow-up
and with lots of unpredictable features that
may emerge during its conduct.
Level 4 is registration of analysis plan and
raw data, which means that I also provide
the detailed information that I have collected
for others to reanalyze, repeat, and also
compare notes if they try to reproduce in
a replication study.
And level 5 is open live streaming where every
day in the morning, I just put online what
are the experiments and what are the analyses
that I'm planning to do for the rest of the
day, or I can do that overnight.
I can get feedback from the whole scientific
community on whether this is a good idea and
whether I could improve any of that.
And then I revisit the analysis or the experimental
plan and I report the results and then I put
my new set of experiments online, and everybody
can comment in a continuing basis.
This is one example of a registered report.
It's part of the reproducibility project,
Cancer Biology.
In a way, these papers have been published
before the research was done.
It's the detailed protocol of what will be
done.
Practically, it can also convey what are the
tables and the figures that will be in the
final paper when the results get accumulated.
So everybody can see that this is the original
intention, and then can compare notes on whether
the original intention was followed.
And the paper is populated with the results
and published.
But there is full correspondence between the
registered report before the research is done
and the registered report after the research
is done.
That's some empirical data here on the public
availability of research data in high impact
factor journals.
These are the journals that have the highest
impact factor across all science and who publish
primary research.
And if you see that green color, that's good
news.
It means that there are editorial policies
in place for sharing information and for making
information available upon request, including
protocols, and also making this a condition
of publication.
And lots of color means that there are these
policies in place.
But the last column shows how many out of
10 of these papers actually adhere to these
policies in each one of these journals.
And there's lots of zeros there, which means
that the policies are in place, but really
implementing them is not easy.
So very often many journals say, do make your
data available.
We encourage you to do that.
But actually, this does not happen.
It's not easy to share data; and many fields
have taken the steps to make that easy, and
common, and widespread.
But others who have less experience probably
see it as an obstacle that is very difficult
to surmount.
widespread.
But others who have less experience probably
see it as an obstacle that is very difficult
to surmount.
And there is always these open questions about
who will prepare these data to make them meaningfully
available, not just throw them out.
And then people would be confused and probably
would get a lot of confusing reanalysis or
reproducibility checks.
Then how quickly should the data become available?
Is there some sort of enforcement that can
be implemented?
Should there be some committee or some way
to sort out whether everybody or some particular
people with particular ideas should be able
to access these data?
How quickly should the data become available?
Within six months?
Within one year?
Many projects don't really finish, and they
can be goldmines to continue to exploit with
further analysis.
Empirically, sharing does not happen often.
This is some data covering the period from
2000 to 2014.
We took a random sample of the entire PubMed,
and we could see that out of the 500 papers,
about half of them included primary data.
But of these 250, only one of them had a full
protocol that had been published, and this
was a separate publication.
And none of them had all their raw data available
for everyone to use with no restrictions.
So even though there is a lot of discussion,
and even though there are fields that do have
data sharing in place, most of the time this
does not happen across the broader biomedical
literature.
There's many efforts to try to enhance and
support and reward some of the practices that
are likely to lead to better reproducibility.
So once that system is the bad system that
has been implemented in the open-science framework,
in several journals in psychology mostly,
but also beyond psychology has started adopting
it.
And basically, the papers can get badges for
openness, for having a protocol, for having
pre-registered protocol, for having raw data
available.
And you can see here that psychological science
journals that adopted that policy had a steep
increase in the percentage of articles that
were reporting available data for other investigators
to use.
But obviously, we don't know what's happening
in other journals and whether people who do
want to have these open and transparent and
sharing policies, eventually clustered to
which the journals reward these policies and
make the journals even more poor in terms
of reproducibility prerequisites.
There is a lot of debate about how to enhance
reproducibility for computational methods.
A few months ago, we published a set of guidelines
for reproducibility aspects that involve data,
code, and workflows.
And the way that we [? can ?] [? seed ?] that
is a set of different levels of reproducibility.
So ideally, you would like to have everything
available and also make sure that someone
has checked every single step of what is being
published.
But realistically, this may not be possible,
because then you need to have the power and
the workforce to be able to go through everything
and repeat everything that has been done.
Therefore, you can consider different levels.
And the lower level would be that someone
would at least check that
the links where the data are supposed to be,
where the software is supposed to be, where
the script is supposed to be-- these links
are functional.
And you can get things to move.
Now, whether you get exactly the same result,
that will take things to a different level.
That would require more effort, and more time,
and more commitment.
Better statistics and methods clearly can
improve the reproducibility record.
As I mentioned earlier, we can think of improving
the transparency of availability of analysis
plans.
Currently, very few studies have their analysis
plans visible before they're done.
I think that there is plenty of room to improve
statistical training, and literacy, and numeracy
of the scientific workforce at all levels--
starting at a very early age-- better study
designs, some standard features that will
promote the trustworthiness of the results.
For example, randomization and blinding of
investigators in animal experiments are very
easy to do, but they're not done.
And finally, some checklists that investigators
in each field would agree are totally essential
to improve the chances of their research being
reproducible.
These are data from in-vivo studies mostly
on animals.
And you see that the vast majority of them
don't use blinding for assessing outcomes.
And they don't use randomization-even though
that would cost nothing and would clearly
enhance the chances of the research being
reproducible.
Institutional practices can also improve reproducibility.
Students, post-doc fellows, investigators
can be trained on practices that improve the
chances of their research being reproducible.
And you can see that as some sort of continued
methodological training.
Currently, we teach our students, and our
fellows, and investigators mostly about subject-matter
details, but less so about the core of experimental
methods, and experimental design, and safeguards
that would promote the reproducibility of
what they do.
And also, institutions can have institution-wide
policies that would be producible practices
and maybe penalize some practices that are
clearly against the needs of reproducibility.
Reporting standards can go quite a long way
in improving transparency about what has been
done.
There's about 300 reporting standards that
you can find in the EQUATOR web site, and
each one of them pertains to one type of study
design or setting.
Many people argue that even though this is
helpful, it is a bit late.
Because once you have a study that has been
done, just reporting what was done-- and sometimes,
what was done might have been suboptimal,
even foolish-- may not be so helpful.
And it's also asking people to accept that,
oh, what I did was completely foolish.
So there is a new wave of such guidance that
is focusing on protocols rather than finished
studies.
And you can also find in EQUATOR a number
of such efforts that focus on what do we need
to build a good protocol for an x type of
design, rather than just wait to report a
study that has already been completed.
Finally, we need empirical research on how
to fix some of these reproducibility problems.
So our metric center at Stanford is really
trying to put together efforts that are focused
around improving research practices and
eventually getting more reproducible research.
This covers issues of methods, of reporting,
of verification or reproducibility per se,
of evaluation, and of rewards.
Because all of these are interconnected in
some way or another.
And there's many initiatives around the world
currently that are focusing on various aspects
of that reproducibility puzzle.
So there's more appearing almost on a weekly
basis.
And very often we see that there is some overlap
in these initiatives-- some redundancy-- some
not necessarily bad redundancy, because I
think that we need more efforts in this sphere--
but also some need of coordination of all
these efforts that are happening across very
different disciplines, and across different
countries, and across different settings.
So at the end of the day, maybe to really
improve reproducibility, we need to make it
have meaning in the reward system.
So we need to find ways to re-engineer our
reward system, which is focused mostly on
productivity.
And I think that productivity is very nice.
I have nothing against productivity.
It's very good for people to be productive,
and published, and get support for their work,
and publish more, and so forth.
But this needs to be tied also with quality,
reproducibility, sharing, and translational
impact of the research.
So I use that acronym of [? PQRST, ?] sounds
like an electrocardiogram.
And currently, we're focusing too much on
the p way.
Well, we need to find ways to reward these
other dimensions that would increase the trustworthiness
of what is being produced.
Scientists do want to see that done.
There's several surveys that suggest that
we do care about reproducibility, and the
scientific community is not just trying to
publish and run away.
We do want to get things right, eventually.
It would be nice to be right at the first
place, but sometimes, we know that this is
not going to happen.
And science makes progress through correcting
itself.
We all do care, though, about getting things
right, eventually, and having reproducible
results that we can trust and also apply.
I will end with a recent paper that is, I
think, a good piece of reading material and
a manifesto for reproducible science that
we published three months ago in Nature Human
Behavior.
It's a coalition of scientists coming from
very different fields, but feeling that there
are some common threats and common opportunities
around reproducibility in that circle of generating
and studying hypotheses, designing, studies
conducted, studies collecting data, analyzing
data, testing hypotheses, interpreting results,
publishing, and then conducting the next experiment
and so forth.
There are these threats that we can deal with
with reproducible practices.
And these practices would depend on different
stakeholders.
Sometimes scientists can make a difference;
other times it would be journals that need
to take the lead.
Funders can be very influential; institutions
can have their share-- and obviously, the
more stakeholders you have in the game in
favor of reproducible research, the more likely
it is that you would get the
stakeholders you have in the game in favor
of reproducible research, the more likely
it is that you would get the results that
you want.
All of the stakeholders involved in science
have sometimes very different types of interest
in research.
Some of them want to see results being published,
so they want publishable research-- others
want fundable research.
Some want to see things work-- translatable
research-- and some want to make profit.
There's nothing wrong with any of these four
ideas about what research should do for us.
But we need to coordinate our efforts and
to have these stakeholders align so that research
eventually would be reproducible.
To conclude, reproducibility has different
meanings across different scientific disciplines.
But eventually, all of them aim at enhancing
our trust in scientific findings.
There's many possible interventions that may
improve the efficiency of research practices
and the reproducibility of the scientific
literature.
We know that some of them work, but we have
very little evidence about many others.
So empirical meta-research would be useful,
not only to assess the prevalence of problems
of reproducibility, but also to assess the
effectiveness and the potential harms of interventions
that try to make research more reproducible.
Thank you.
Thank you, John.
That was fantastic.
And I really appreciate your coming this morning.
We already have a million questions-- well,
at least a dozen questions in the question
box.
Those of you who want to pose questions to
John, please type your questions in there.
I will try to select questions that I think
are going to be easier to answer, and I'll
editorialize a little bit in the interest
of time, since there's not much time left
this morning.
First question in the question box says, "Many
of my colleague scientists state that these
claims of unreproducibility are overblown.
They often say that we know who does poor
work, and we know who does good work.
And in the end, science is self-correcting.
So should we not overreact?
That by shaking the system, we could do much
more damage to the scientific process or enterprise,
which is so good for society."
What is your response?
I guess the corollary question is, how do
we know that most meta-research papers are
not false?
[LAUGHS] So I think that meta-research papers
have their own share of irreproducibility,
no doubt.
But I think that reproducibility is at the
core of the scientific method.
So it's not really something new.
I think that science has always made progress
because it's focusing on better methods, better
scrutiny, better ability to correct itself.
So I don't see that as a new message that
is disrupting science.
In a way, it is just supporting science and
offering the real value of science, which
is exactly that it can correct itself.
There's clearly vast differences across different
fields in terms of how much lack of reproducibility
we see; and also, in terms of what it means
not to see a result being reproduced.
I think that the connotations are very different;
the implications are very different.
But at the end of the day, any effort to correct
a scientific record more efficiently, more
quickly, more rigorously, more robustly, is
only going to
make science look better, not worse.
There is some school of thought that says
that, well, these are difficult times.
But you know, it has always been difficult
times for science, unfortunately.
Science is the best thing that has happened
to humans, but this is something that many
people don't realize.
So let's just forget about this and just try
to claim that science knows everything, and
everything that we publish is correct.
Well, this is a very dangerous path because
if we do that, there will be lots of cases
of-- easily some results will be shown to
be incorrect.
And then, we are just giving ammunition to
our critics that we were overconfident in
results that we shouldn't have been overconfident
with.
So I do believe that to defend science, we
need to defend the scientific method, not
some conception of scientists being absolutely
correct all the time, which is not what science
is about.
OK, one of the listeners says that in fact,
we need to go back to Popper's idea of the
scientific method, where we don't try to prove
hypotheses, which is impossible to do, but
to eliminate alternatives.
Any thoughts there?
I think that this is pretty much done already
to a good extent.
And I think that there's also that higher
level of integration of knowledge where indeed,
we may be eliminating some hypotheses and
making others more likely.
I would prefer to see things in a Bayesian
view and think of the cumulative evidence
kind of affecting our priors and generating
some posterior.
There are some posteriors that are extremely
strong, and I will not be convinced otherwise,
unless there is amazingly extraordinary evidence
to the contrary.
So you know, climate change, or tobacco killing
people, or MMR is safe.
I can't think of what evidence would persuade
me that these statements are not correct.
Many other statements just have some modest,
or high, or low credibility.
And they have some alternatives that also
have modest, low, or high credibility.
And as we accumulate more data, we can fine
tune where our beliefs emerge.
And sometimes we need to act based on relatively
modest credibility.
And we don't need to wait until we know something
100% to be sure and until we have eliminated
every other alternative.
Because what is at stake may require immediate
action, even in the face of uncertainty.
But I think if we see things from that perspective,
it makes sense that we can have a gradient
of certainty and uncertainty for different
types of scientific findings, hypotheses,
and their alternatives.
John, do you have any thoughts on how we can
apply analysis of reproducibility to studies
that involve clinical data?
I guess, particularly EHR data that are collected
opportunistically, not as part of a specific
protocol where HIPAA may interfere with our
ability to make data public.
I think that there's many opportunities for
reproducibility in this sphere.
Clearly, EHR data have their own peculiarities;
but in essence, there is many datasets, many
databases that depend on EHR.
And some of them
may have incompatibilities against each other,
but there is also some crosstalk opportunities.
So there are opportunities to compare notes
across EHR platforms, and data, and analysis.
And in many situations, there may be opportunities
also to compare notes of some of the inferences
made from EHR data against other traditional
types of designs, including in some cases
even randomized controlled trials that may
have addressed a similar question.
So I think that this is a space where you
could think of a pretty robust reproducibility
agenda and try to map the performance of these
datasets in comparisons within themselves,
between themselves, and in comparison with
other methods of making inference of these
effects.
A listener noticed that you talked about reproducibility
in the biomedical and behavioral sciences.
What can you tell us about physical sciences
or chemical sciences?
So, there is also work done on reproducibility
and related [? themes ?] in the physical sciences--
probably less compared to social sciences
and biomedical sciences-- but we do have several
pieces of evidence.
The general perception is that physics and
chemistry have higher reproducibility, and
to a large extent this is true.
There are some simple reasons for that.
Usually, there is stronger experimental design.
There is more determinism in their data.
They have a stronger history of transparency
and sharing.
So for example, everything in high energy
and particle physics practically shared with
a large community of tens of thousands of
physicists who can look at the and eventually,
they all publish their results together.
They have very stringent statistical rules
for claiming discoveries.
So they have a five sigma rule that is equivalent
to a p-value of 10 to the minus 7, which is
very close to the genome-wide level of significance
that is used in biomedicine that has worked
pretty well in genome association studies
for example.
So there's many reasons why you see a pretty
good reproducibility in the sciences.
There's also great tolerance for negative
results.
Most of the results in experimental physics
are negative, practically, and nobody worries
about that.
You see all these papers coming out from CERN,
hundreds of papers, they have found one higgs
boson and pretty much nothing else.
That was a great discovery, but I would say
it's an equally great discovery that all the
other results are negative, and people just
say that this is what they are.
There are still some problems in specific
fields-- that the experimentation or the observation
is more difficult.
For example, claims for exoplanets-- about
50% of the time they turn out to be non-reproducible--
range from 25% to 60% in different surveys.
Some of the more recent wave of chemical synthesis
have been a bit difficult to reproduce [? in
?] [? dependent ?] labs, but I hope that this
is the exception.
So no scientific field is immune to these
problems because these are not necessarily
problems, this is the scientific method.
And you know, it's difficult to do good science.
That's great.
And on that note, we should end this.
We've reached the end of the hour.
John, let me thank you for what was a really
stimulating talk.
And then let me thank all the people who dialed
in this morning.
It was really great to hear you.
Thanks again.
Thank you.